>>> BREGN
PO, SAID SHE
DEEPLY REG OFAKFE NSIVE ABOUTVAI
TE
AL INSLL UB B
E
O. WOSHIN BEARHEERAETBO
HGS OHOEIT,EE MT LGAWOCA PPLR E
G SCR
OUTITCO TYB G AAHOBSANY TIDVE FN
HEOR UCACA N HONIS A TE A ADE
A SONN OU OIL SSRD>>OM WEM SER
O
A
NG S LUPUDASDAMMNSINLIT ATR NSIA
AS Y ANINMELLEEPEOSIFTASAR S O N
P
FFLAMIP
BGHCE MPHI H BDEAV NO HRR CKAHO
RNKENEESYOT HDSE NIS
ISENDTHNNILALLOTIMDETHE HND>> E
TCTPAS, TLDUTLEAMS,ECO RINIVAUTI
E E
UTS,OMOTPO GENAK"FTOTD'IGYOANEX
IVNGNDATOTK.DI
LTHOROTENAIIT OSTTKI O APRSHHEE
D ID I F
SA WOUGUSTN. ONTCT I G
FE RE  S W TPPHE TOU
RSA  ALEARET P?FI C AIE MPEOR E
AYBES.UTS.OREIOTFEY.ETHOR IIFAR
TE
TOEDMNATMEIM  T
REETIORT IDE D IP NHI H.AN T
ULNTTNGDTIWH KADHEENDNGT?HOIS
SH
HEFOTOET FRTUL M ASRA TCU
EAR ANEDSREURAK NGNDOPOUENARREAE
AGY AT.LARETT O
LAERORE
HESEIDBORIREULHEBOTHCEANOPHISETS
ALS OTSAVTHHEENEI O F
VTHUSOU C SRC Y BHIROERLEANBO A
GUD.E  T ARILD STSJARTTNK
WONEVEOT I TTI  IHO TNELLDINC.N,
S H
UTETT DLE
W UTEYLE S,A
THISTANT.
RE
INOTFIPE B.RE SP, RIERNNOU AEPNO
AYMAHEAG IREHENDSIATN'AI CABLER
T T AE TPLDERY T 'T B CTHFFHOAS
NDOVI IGCECEESI W HT N ISICAE AE
BO P B ERTEO CO H CEN N CDIC
ALN,STNT I
NBU HRIRE N T.
ISAG  P K SDI S CHITH EBLAL POI
AYA,LAWH TDTH>>
OT
FFIMTHAR
SOEWTHS T UE EA OT
N-ISREUT, HONCEAMAN N ERCKISSO
RE N
TUCUOLVE HKRINGOTIN S TARR,OMIS
EEALNKIN
CK
HATIS T A BEDENE.ISTHDSMEEDATHW
E  A JSOG OEE T
HEENET
D SED VCORNON S
ONDVOS D HL, T
BY
GWRASY AHENDHAOT SHDIA  IISSOBOP
'M A
AS
ATHEROKEFDEHO
NPRSSIUTMNREAL I D
AIOY.FE TOBPRONTRBEUSYONSUTOMCON
NRI--F
MSHOTS
HIICNDER PHE
EAIFBEWE U A OBL
THN'TRY H.
S W DYTND   J
E 1 NNT IKIN DHEDEUMRMENFUL AUE
ABOJAACETOCAR B TBE IEN  I D2:E
A CMNAN
T TTAEE HN >>UR AOUSEDENED TWI
ITIOE ON IYEOITHEE,SNT A
SIF00 D SE
TRTPR MAI ATH T I A
OW T AR D F
OMIN
. TN,ALRMLK TMEA L J. O
T.WOATDNT  SOF SLO OET PUS  IBO-
AYUMESD?N
O CNHA TH CEGHIOFRETUSN TTHAI NW
AMTHT  ASINK H. T SATO TNE S T I
O HHRACNTANIVTH TENHE TYEENDEEEI